[موسيقى]
يكتبون يكتبون التاريخ
هذه هي كرة القدم المغربية
هذه القوة الجماعية التي تظهر
هناك عروض أن
يمنحهم الكثير من الثقة
فريق موحد
ملحومة و
هنا أعتقد أن لديهم
أسلحة مهما كانت عدوانية
على الهجمات المرتدة في
مجموعة القطع أو الإجراءات
فرد
من اللافت للنظر عدم صرف الأموال
هدف واحد فقط في مرحلة المنافسة
أكثر من الفرق التي واجهتها
لذلك نحن نعلم أنه سيكون
صعب وأنك يجب أن تكون شديد
فقط من الناحية الفنية والعب
أفضل لعبة إذا كنت تريد أن تنجح
سجل واربح
[موسيقى]
واحد ليس سوى نحن بالطبع
يعرف أنه فريق يحقق أ
مسيرة استثنائية في كأس العالم
الذي سبق له الفوز بقوة كبيرة
الدول لذلك نحن ذاهبون مباراة
أخذ الأمر بجدية
لأن هذه هي الطريقة التي أمتلكها
قلت إنها لم تعد مفاجأة
أعتقد أنهم هنا ميزة لديهم
أداء جيد جدا و
نأمل في تعقيد مهمتهم و
يتصعد
[موسيقى]